lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
empezar a practicar cómo restar
decimales vamos a practicarlo poco a
poco en futuros vídeos aprenderemos a
hacerlo cada vez más rápido y en
situaciones más complicadas digamos que
tenemos tres decimos menos dos decimos
cuál es el resultado bueno hay muchas
maneras de abordar esto y los animo que
pausa en el vídeo y que traten de
resolverlo ustedes solos antes de que lo
revisemos juntos supongo que ya lo
hicieron así que hagámoslo juntos
podemos ver esto como tres décimos y le
vamos a quitar los décimos si tenemos
tres de alguna cosa y le quitamos dos de
eso con cuánto nos quedamos bueno nos va
a quedar uno me voy a quedar con un
décimo y podemos visualizar esto voy a
poner aquí un entero y este entero está
dividido en décimos y vemos que tres de
estos décimos están coloreados
estas tres barras verdes representan los
tres décimos ahora queremos quitar dos
décimos entonces quitamos un décimo
y luego quitamos otro décimo
con cuánto nos vamos a quedar bueno nos
quedamos con este décimo que tenemos
aquí este es el único décimo que nos
queda de los tres ahora basándonos en
esta idea tratemos de construir
situaciones más complejas
digamos que tenemos 1.5 o 1 y 5 decimos
a esto le queremos restar 0.77 decimos
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
hay un par de formas en que podemos
resolver esto y yo les voy a decir la
manera en que lo hago en mi mente
déjenme reescribir esto podemos ver esto
como uno más
5 decimos menos 7 decimos y podemos ver
este entero como 10 decimos un entero es
igual a 10 decimos así que esto es 10
decimos más cinco decimos
-7 decimos entonces podemos decir que
estos son 15 décimos en la mente lo
podemos hacer más rápido si tienes 1.5
puedes decir rápidamente 1.5 es igual a
15 decimos menos 7 decimos entonces
tenemos que 15 menos 7 es igual a 8 esto
es igual a 8 decimos lo que estoy
haciendo es pensar en términos de
decimos en lugar de pensar en 1 y 5
decimos si de alguna manera pudiéramos
poner 15 en la posición de los décimos y
decir que aquí tenemos 0 enteros y que
tenemos 15 décimos y luego le restamos 7
décimos para obtener los 8 decimos que
es 0.8 y 8 decimos
ahora hay otra forma de abordar esto
vamos a este paso y podemos pensar en
cuánto es 17 decimos podemos verlo como
1 menos siete décimos y luego sumar a
estos cinco décimos entonces tenemos uno
menos siete decimos uno es igual a diez
décimos y si le quitó siete décimos me
voy a quedar con tres décimos más cinco
decimos que una vez más es igual a ocho
décimos
y hay otra manera en que podemos abordar
esto como les he dicho vamos a revisar
la mayor cantidad de formas de resolver
esto para que vean cómo podemos abordar
la misma idea de diferentes maneras
vamos a dibujar una recta numérica de
este lado
digamos que aquí está el cero y luego
aquí está el uno dos tres cuatro cinco
seis siete ocho nueve diez
este es uno
1 2 3
45 este es 1.5 y tenemos que restar 7
decimos una forma en que podemos hacerlo
es decir bueno vamos a quitar 5 décimos
y llegamos a uno y luego quitamos otros
dos decimos lo que nos va a llevar a
ocho décimos oa 0.8 así que lo hice de
esta manera porque es lo mismo que tener
1.5 menos 5 decimos menos dos décimos y
la razón por la que separe los siete
décimos de esta manera es que es muy
sencillo y directo resolver 1.5 menos 5
decimos
1 y 5 decimos menos 5 decimos esto es
igual a 1 le estoy quitando los 5
décimos y ahora solo tenemos que quitar
dos décimos uno menos dos décimos y una
vez más el resultado es ocho decimos
todas estas son formas perfectamente
legítimas de abordar este problema y
esta es la manera en que mucha gente
incluyéndome lo resolvemos en la mente